pokemon means pocket monster or having
pocket-sized demons as friends there
seems to be more than one of these types
of games that have a theme of calling up
or communicating with demons
the show is full of witches and demons
and even a gender-bending character
with flash and passion to give our
pokemon pretty faces to extend our art
to outer spaces
jesse james
jesse
[Music]
listen to me kid when you get involved
with the opposite sex you're only asking
for trouble yes and that's the kind of
trouble i stay out of
i am a flaming moltres
i think that costume came right out of
his closet and pokemon go was released
in the us and became an instant hit fans
were running all over the towns and
cities trying to collect as many pocket
demons as possible this anime nudged its
fandom one step closer to inviting
demons into their physical space not
something you ever want to do if you're
a true believer in the spiritual realm